shorty that's what it is
nice to see you if that man looks
familiar it's because that's
shorty the one-time homeless man that
khloe kardashian befriended on season
one of keeping up with the kardashians
do you want my bracelet to remember me
it's an angel wing so you're always
going to be protected during thursday's
episode of keeping up with the
kardashians
the good american founder gave fans some
major nostalgia by tracking down
shorty isn't that crazy in episode 7 of
the hit show's premiere season
chloe welcomed shorty into the family's
home and gave him a makeover after she
found him outside of their dash store
in 2007. come with me in my car
and i want to take you to get showered
and cleaned up okay
so this is our house yeah welcome
while the family hadn't seen shorty in
13 years
chloe said fans would often reach out to
her on social media to report shorty
sightings
and others were curious to know how he
was doing
the number one thing i get asked is
literally how shorty have you guys heard
from him
is he alive i get asked all
all the time we've looked for him a
couple times um
he used to be on hollywood and highland
and we would look for him and
no one has been able to really find him
but a couple people have found him
um like his whereabouts they just like
send photos or i'm tagged in some random
photos
it's always nice to know that he's still
alive and he seems like he's doing well
it's never a dull moment well once they
found shorty
he revealed he had lost his job at a
laundromat due to covid19
and he was hoping to find a new job and
an apartment
he's um saving up to get an apartment
yeah i want one of my own
that's amazing i'm trying to get
something i can call my own
or something my own i call home
yeah it's so different from where we
left off before
in season one he really was adamant that
he did not want to get off the streets
so now he wants
to create a better healthier environment
for himself and we're all for that
that's when the kardashians swooped in
we know that shorty is trying to better
himself and get this apartment for
himself and we want
to help as much as we can and also we
want to make it a surprise it's
important for him to get
this specific apartment that's rent
controlled and we'll we're definitely
going to do what we can to help him
yep they surprised shorty by helping him
secure
a rent-controlled apartment
for me oh you got your little gift
yeah well good when are you going to
move into your place
i hope so soon too that's so exciting
we're so proud of you
come on i want to play something you
deserve a place of your own
you deserve it shorty of course this is
the final season of keeping up
and shorty's appearance is just one of
many nods to the show's 20 seasons that
we can expect before the series comes to
an
end tune in because you never know
what's going to happen
in a promo for next week's episode the
family makes the tough decision to end
keeping up we all have to be on the same
page because it's a huge decision
it was just the hardest conversation
that we've ever had to have
back in september shortly after the
family announced that the show would be
coming to an end
ryan seacrest who is an executive
producer on keeping up
told et the family's choice to walk away
was not an easy one
in talking to the family this was a very
very hard decision for them to make and
and i know even you know before and
after the announcement came
out they were emotional we were trading
texts and emails after the announcement
uh and you look back at 14 years and 20
seasons of a camera
in your life and think about that at
some point you're gonna say
you know we did it we had a great run
we're going to live with a little more
privacy in our lives and i think they
just felt like
now is the time to do it